visiting a clinic where there are
children to to a bed and lying on the
floor suffering from malaria makes a
pretty strong impression I am Nicholas P
for recent TV and today we are talking
with Donald Roberts and Richard trenor's
of the new book the excellent powder
DDT's political and scientific history
thanks for joining us thanks for having
you what is excellent about DDT
well DDT is a chemical that has saved
hundreds of millions of lives since
protected billions of people from the
threat of insect borne diseases and what
could be more excellent than that and
it's done so without harming human
health okay now this is clearly not to
receive the wisdom or the popular well I
guess it's not the received scientific
wisdom unfortunately and it's not the
popular understanding of DDT we know DDT
destroys Eagle eggs and makes people
sprout extra arms and things so what's
what's behind the disjuncture
disjuncture basically he is a product of
fear campaigns that were started back in
the 60s and they have been continued to
present time fear campaigns that
involved that linked to potential are
theoretical harm to wildlife as well as
theoretical harm to human health those
harms simply don't exist if you look
carefully at the scientific record but
the perception exist in the minds of the
public and one of the flash points for
that was Rachel Carson in the 60s with
Silent Spring right that's where the
kind of modern environmental movement
grows out of that and she the finger DDT
and other kinds of insecticides and
chemicals at use what was there is there
any science I mean you're saying that
DDT does not harm the environment or
does not harm human beings saying that
DDT does not inflict severe harm on
wildlife
are the environment and it does not
inflict severe harm on human health
but when you look at the way DDT is used
in malaria control where it's sprayed on
house walls not in the environment not
not broads broadly distributed in the
environment then it becomes literally
unavailable for doing the kinds of harm
that many of the campaigners against the
use of insecticides in public health
claim what is the legal status of DDT in
throughout the world and it's most
needed in the in the developing world
right right
DDT has been banned in most places for
use in agriculture it still remains
available for use in public health and
under the Stockholm convention which is
a UN convention to ban persistent
organic pollutants there is an exemption
for use in public health so it still can
be used however there is a deadline that
has been set by 2017 where the UN
stockin Convention was to a halt in all
production of DDT and an elimination
completely by 2020 so no more production
after 2017 so it still can be used
what's interesting and what's been
happening over the past few years is
that even though the US government is
now funding use of DDT through a very
good malaria control program the growing
regulations on how you can use in these
insecticides has made it more difficult
to use more less available and more
expensive to store transporting news and
so regulations this cut is kind of
pricing it out of the out of the market
and there are few producers now the the
one of the big producers was China and
they in compliance with the UN
Convention on these UN conventions Dhaka
convention have a cease production so
how many how many lives could you know a
more robust use of DDT safe it could
have huge impact on the
the amount of disease that we have in
the developing countries today huge
impact and the reason we know that for
absolute certainty is that we already
have a history of how effective it can
be by the by 1969 when the global
eradication program was brought to
abruptly brought to an end it had
literally freed a roughly a billion
people from endemic disease that was DDT
and DDT alone and so we have that
history we know it can be very very
effective so I mean we're talking about
billions of people yes and there are no
easily available alternatives or there
are alternative insecticides that can be
used there are none that work in the way
English DDT works and we devote a
substantial portion of the book to
describing the the modes of action of DT
that this is this the conventional
wisdom is that insecticides kill
mosquitoes that the only good mosquito
is a dead mosquito in fact that's false
and there's decades of evidence that
shows that DDT stops mosquitoes from
coming into houses it works as a spatial
repellent there are no other
replacements exercise their work in that
way there's growing resistance to these
other insecticides and we're seeing
growing pressure from some scientists
and from activist groups against the use
of those chemicals and what we fear and
one of the reasons for writing this book
is that if if these groups do - DDT what
they just saw redo - these other
chemicals what they have done to DDT we
face serious problems with Disease
Control and not just in the developing
world but in the developed world as well
talk very briefly about why are you
interested in this topic or how did how
did you come to this topic well my
interest dates back to the 1970s I was
conducting research along with a team of
other researchers in
amazon basin we were looking for
studying disease epidemiology and so i
became very curious as to how this
chemical when sprayed on house walls
good hath such a tremendous impact and
so eventually I had the opportunity to
carry out some studies in a very remote
area of the Amazon base and and so I
produced two built these experimental
huts and we studied very carefully the
movement of mosquitoes into and out of
these huts and then after a couple of
years of study we sprayed one of them
and quite frankly the result of that
experiment changed my whole professional
life because what I observed was that as
soon as the house was sprayed that was
the end of the mosquitoes coming into
that house now in a unsprayed house that
was nearby
the mosquitoes continued coming in and
biting throughout the night but in this
great house that was it and that that
protection that prevention of mosquitoes
coming into the house at nighttime and
biting which is the time they
transmitted disease that protection was
was continuing twelve months later from
one spray richard what
what's your the origin of your interest
well i i'm like dawn I'm not a
entomologist or specialist in tropical
disease I'm an economist and I was
interested in the environment and
development and when I was living in
South Africa at the time when the
Stockholm Convention on persistent
organic pollutants was being negotiated
there was a massive malaria epidemic and
it was precisely because DDT was taken
out of use in South Africa and there was
a resistance to the alternative
insecticides and I got interested in
this it was I knew nothing about DT but
spoke to many malaria scientists about
about these problems and visited these
malaria areas where you know visiting a
clinic where there are children to to a
bed and lying on the floor suffering
from malaria makes a pretty strong
impression
and I got interested because you know
through that and have continued that was
in 99 2000 and have continued to
campaign on this and we were right in
the book to set the record straight
basically and very briefly tell us
what's the title come from the excellent
powder it comes from a speech that
Winston Churchill made in 1944 when he
explained that they were using the
excellent DDT powder to save the lives
of troops and civilians in the European
and Pacific theatres of war
I want to thank Don Roberts and Richard
trend authors of the excellent powder
DDT's political and scientific history
for recent TV I'm Nick Gillespie
you